Gabriella how you doing
good I can barely hear you though can
you turn up your mic or your volume a
little bit I'm not sure
oh okay maybe just a little bit more
Raise Your Voice a little bit for me or
bring the phone closer
um is there anything that you disagree
with with what we just covered with this
whole Jonah Hill thing like what do you
think of that situation
I I feel like he knew who he was dating
going into the relationship so if things
like that were going to be an issue for
him he should have never dated her
yeah I mean I said it earlier but
the way that it should work is when you
cross that
when you cross a Rubicon and it's like
hey you know let's get into a
relationship like let's be exclusive
like you want to claim each other then
that's when you want to deal with okay
well leaning into the future what kind
of Lifestyle are we going to have or
share or build or life that we're going
to build together and if it's not a line
and she's like I want to keep doing what
I'm doing and he says well I want to
have a family those are two totally
different paths and absolutely he should
find somebody that's a better fit not
try to fit a square peg in a round hole
so I think that he did make a mistake I
think the whole misogynist and finger
pointing on him is a little bit offside
I mean
what I know of him I don't I don't think
that's it
um so that's a fair comment
um you're in a situationship it's it
sounds like here from the comments that
that you were just on the whatever
podcast and there's a talk about that
can you can you fill me in yeah so I was
just on the whatever podcast
um I talked a lot about
um my current relationship situationship
so I was with my boyfriend ex-boyfriend
for the last three years
um he I'm 28 he's 33. he lives with his
mom
um he's a lawyer he's financially stable
he just prefers to stay over there and
just as mom not Mom and Dad it's just
Mom
like two years of yours isn't just him
and her and her okay
so are you guys still seeing each other
or like
what exactly is like okay I have an idea
what a situationship is but I think
everybody's interpretation or definition
of it is going to vary can you can you
explain what the situationship looks
like today
um so I broke up with him in January
um I dated a few other people he dated a
few other people we ended up getting
back together and then I broke up with
him again in June
why'd you guys break up in January and
then again in June
go visit like one of my best friends
um in Florida over Christmas time
extended my trap my trip like through
the holiday and he doesn't really
celebrate Christmas and he basically
like ignored me the entire time that I
was there hung up on me on Christmas
left me at LAX like didn't pick me up I
had to take a 200 Uber to go home I was
just really mad so I ended up leaving
him in January
um and then we ended up getting back
together and then the main reason that I
got back together with him was because
he was going to make a compromise that
he was going to come over to my
apartment more
um but he hasn't made the compromise so
he wants me to always go over to his
mom's house and his mom doesn't like me
I don't really like his mom so yeah so
let me just go back to the trip down to
Florida so you live in L.A so you flew
to Florida to visit a friend friend was
a guy or a girl a girl and like a long
time friend that you've known
okay did you guys have the talk by that
point like hey you know where do we
stand are we going to be exclusive are
we boyfriend girlfriend or were you just
sort of dating at that time together for
okay so for two years all right so that
so that kicked out kicked off that and
then the second time that you guys broke
up is because he wasn't coming over to
your place
for like the last three years and I just
like came to realization that that's
kind of weird and was kind of putting my
foot down like hey you need to come over
here more and
he said that he would do that if I got
back together with him and he just never
did
and he was just saying like I'm a lawyer
I don't have time for it I'm like I'm a
tech recruiter I don't have time to
always go to your mom's like why does he
live with his mommy
um I think they've always been really
close and like they live in a large
house and he doesn't want her to be
alone
okay it's his house or is it her house
so he lives in her house does he have
any other siblings
he has one other
one at his mom's other houses and the
stepdad lives there too or he doesn't
live there
a little bit crazy so stepdad left and
you don't get along with Mom
that's kind of an awkward scenario isn't
it and like why would you I mean I'm
trying to picture this I'm 33 I live
with my mom in a big house how big is a
house
it's like five bedrooms like is it like
big enough where it's like he's got his
West Wing and you can do whatever you
want the west wing and nobody can hear
anything and it's just like your own
area of the house okay so it's all
together okay so I'm 33 and I'm living
with my mom
Okay so
okay so I'm 33 I'm leaving my mom and I
work as a lawyer lawyers jobs suck at 33
because you're working long ass hours
right like Max wife's a lawyer so I know
what that's like
um because you gotta climb you know the
ranks you know put in your time so that
sucks so he's got a point with the whole
travel thing how far away do you live
from him
15 minutes that's not far I would like
my apartment
closer to his jaw
his job yeah this doesn't make any sense
I mean I would
remote so it doesn't really like he can
definitely like stay here if he if you
really wanted to that sounds weird
um I mean I'm I mean I remember back
when I met my girlfriend she was living
with her parents
um and she always came over to my house
was never like you know come over to my
parents house and hang out with me over
there because that would just be weird
um
it's weird
it's weird that shit's not normal I get
like you know like the lawyer in the
long hours and they like to be in
control of stuff like if you get with a
lawyer you have to understand like their
whole day is arguing back and forth with
the other side and their point is they
they always do their best to get the
best possible final draft that serves
them and their clients so they can have
that win right so
that's that's something you're always
going to deal with when you deal with a
lawyer I tell guys all the time don't
date lawyers right like don't get
involved with women that are lawyers
because they're going to run your life
unless you like that like unless you
like your life run and being with
somebody like that bossy most guys at my
level don't so I just discourage it I
say don't do it it's not it's not going
to be a great experience so you're
dealing with that which is why he's so
firm about not coming over you know
something doesn't go his way hangs up he
doesn't pick you up at the airport lets
you take the Uber home that's what
you're going to deal with with a guy
that's in that profession right and he's
always and he's showing you these these
cards right
what's your long-term goal like what are
you looking for you're looking for a
boyfriend you're looking for family you
said you're 28 right
see that with him but I just it would
have to be past the whole like you'd end
up
yeah but yeah I was gonna say like you'd
end up living in his mom's house
with them I mean and you don't even get
along with her
yeah but actions Express priorities I
mean he also said that he was going to
come and see you too right
right exactly so I mean he doesn't have
the best track record of like being able
to trust him on his promises yeah so
yeah it's the same it might be best
yeah it's the same thing with
um you know watching behaviors versus
words right actions Express priorities
if if somebody says one thing but they
do something else you have to always
believe the behavior right
same thing goes for women like watch the
dude you know if he says something but
he does something else watch the
behavior right trust trust the behavior
because that's the best indicator of
what you're dealing with and what he's
going to do going forward in the future
so it doesn't sound like a good fit to
me like why are you playing the
situation ship card still like why are
you still seeing this
[Music]
I think like I'm really sad without him
and I'm really bad at breakups so I
almost would rather just stay with him
and just not go through it right now
what if you're if you're willing to
enter his frame and do everything that
he wants go to him all the time you know
live with them you know when he wants to
settle down and stuff like that then
you're gonna have to make those
concessions but
I would not want to I mean
I just can't see in any environment or
situation where it would be cool living
with my girlfriend and one of her
parents
well the thing is like when I first
started dating him he was like fresh out
of law school so I just thought it was
going to be a phase like I thought he
was like it doesn't seem like it doesn't
have a job whatever it was he's lived
with like his ex-girlfriends in the past
so I thought he would just eventually
move out but uh yeah no it I don't think
it's gonna happen even his mom would
tell me like to my face like he's not
moving with you is he Italian or
Portuguese or something
okay all right well it's the same thing
you know living with mom
um
is your place uncomfortable is it is it
tiny is there nowhere to park a car
and he can park his car somewhere
yeah I would give him my parking spot in
the lot like yeah
he just never really he comes for one
hour on Wednesday evenings
uh look I wouldn't do
situationships on either side whether
it's guys or gals right a situationship
sounds to me like it's kind of like in
limbo it's halfway time flies Gabriella
okay like time moves really really fast
in life and before you know it you're
gonna be 40 you're gonna be 50 you're
going to be 60. if you don't deal with
like time in my opinion it actually
feels and I hate using the word feels
but it actually feels like it moves
faster the older you get like your 20s
moves a lot slower than your 40s
right so you so you have to be aware
that situationships are just time eaters
they're time wasters
if your goal is long-term with this guy
you see a future
and his thing is he's not you know
coming to see you or
you have a difficult time with his mom
it ain't gonna get better
I think from like everything that I've
read from like the comments from like
whatever podcast like listening to my
friends like it may just be time to move
on
um sounds like it
good luck with that though
did you have any other questions
all right you take care
thank you so yeah ciao I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out